welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled how to improve her2
testing accuracy
incorporating the 2018 asco cap focused
update
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
hattie yazaji
the medical director of vitro molecular
laboratories in miami florida
dr yaziji's area of expertise is breast
pathology and breast cancer biomarkers
especially her2 protein and gene testing
dr yaziji has received several
prestigious achievement awards including
alpha omega alpha honor medical society
and the southern medical association
pathology section achievement award
he has also co-authored over 55
publications
in peer-reviewed journals for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions following the presentation
please join me in welcoming dr hattie
yasiji
i will now turn the presentation over to
him dr yaziji
thank you very much jennifer for the
nice introduction i appreciate it i
appreciate the invitation
so we
i have a couple disclosures
to make which are on the slide and i
would like to dedicate the talk to all
of the
breast cancer survivors including her
two positive
patients so just a quick word about
myself with her too
[Music]
i believe we published one of the first
if not the first
quality assurance programs on her2
testing with fish you know when i was a
resident
in pathology prior to it actually toward
the end of my residency and beginning of
my
first fellowship that's when
therapeutic applications of antiher2
targeted therapy became available and
approved by the regulatory agencies
and but nobody taught us
how to perform the test how to interpret
the test
so i have to confess i'm actually a
self-taught
fish pathologist nobody taught me how to
read this slide
and the first time i was introduced to
the term
to the acronym fish which is
fluorescence and cytopodization
um is when i believe uh
there was a talk at the city at the
kosair children's hospital by a renowned
uh sector geneticist actually
uh dr hirsch and he was talking about
the use of
this new test new technology called fish
to detect fragile x syndrome you know
and that was uh just a
basically a grand round presentation in
1993 i believe
and nothing else happened after that
until
99 when fish was approved as one of the
testing modalities
in for her too and
i was asked as a junior pathologist by
my senior
pathologist all right you're going to
start our fish program
great wonderful exciting but how do we
do it
so actually i designed the quality
insurance program to correlate between
ihc and fish
and we published our findings in 2004
um i was fortunate enough to participate
in the asco cap
task force discussions i was not my name
is not included in the articles because
i was
representing one of the commercial
laboratories so we are not supposed to
be co-authors
but we participated in the setting the
guidelines on the discussions
our laboratory adjudicates the
her discrepancus status between oncotype
results and
the originating her2 results whether the
testing was done by imminence to
chemistry or fish
and we actually validated some of the
commercially available her2 assays
and that would be actually another
disclosure
um developed an assay to use
immunofluorescence and fish
in special settings where it is
necessary
to localize the target area better
because the with the fish it is
difficult to recognize the topography
where the tumor is the invasive tumor
where the dcis
is if there is dcis and where the benign
areas
are
so this is the agenda we're going to
have a quick introduction
and jump straight through into some
common misconceptions
after that we will discuss the focused
updates
um and then we'll spend a few minutes
talking about these
gray zone tumors what i would like to
refer to them as grazon tumors
and then we'll mention uh the some
special scenarios
you know i have personally looked at
over 23 000
fish slides related to her2 in breast
cancer
so i have i can say that i i have seen
it all actually so we'll
we'll go over some of these special
scenarios and then
spend the last few minutes to discuss
how to improve
her2 testing accuracy and these are
helpful hints that i
apply myself so everything i say here
everything i advocate
i actually do so what i do what i say i
do
it's there and then we'll open it to
questions and we'll be mindful of the
time hopefully there will be sufficient
amount of time for questions afterward
so this is a kind of a probe diagram so
the
her2 fish assay includes two probes
one that targets the actual gene which
is a locus specific probe
uh the gene is located on the long arm
of chromosome 17 and it's actually close
enough to the centromere
which poses some issues actually which
we'll we'll
uh briefly touch on later and the
control probe is the centromere
uh pro
the green color
okay so to the right of of that
chromosome map there is an illustration
of a negative result which is basically
what you see
in about 80 of breast cancers
and then uh underneath that a positive
result
where which we which we you would see in
the remaining
uh percentage uh now um
the mechanism
of her2 protein expression is gene
amplification
now that covers the vast majority of
scenarios now it doesn't cover 100
of them there are exceptions but these
exceptions in my opinion are exceedingly
rare so
her2 protein expression is a direct
result
of her2 gene amplification
again with rare exceptions and we do see
these rare exceptions every once in a
while
now given the fact that the drug targets
the protein
and doesn't target the gene uh
the protein status becomes more
informative for treatment decisions than
gene status
and that's an important point from a
therapeutic standpoint
so if there are oncologists listening to
this talk
anytime there is a discrepancy which is
in my opinion
exceedingly rare between the protein
status and the gene status anytime there
is a discrepancy
we rely more on the protein status than
the gene status for
treatment purposes okay because again
the drug
doesn't target the gene it targets the
protein so that's important to remember
but the good news is the those scenarios
where there is discrepancy
are few and far between
so this illustrates a her2 negative
tumor
on the left side with a negative
immunistic chemistry and negative
fish associated with it and
her2-positive tumor
on the right side with a positive or two
protein expression which is basically a
membranous chicken wire pattern
and a positive fish assay which shows an
increased number of those
red colored gene labeled
probes i'm sorry fluorescently labeled
so just a very quick word about the
targeted therapy
biology there are we're not going to get
into
the pathways the cancer pathways
associated with her2 gene expression but
just a quick word
about the how the
increase copy number of the gene leads
to an increase of protein copy number
and how that
affects the biology of her2 positive
breast cancers
we actually don't know the exact answer
but it seems like
the dimerization just by the fact that
the her2 receptors become extremely
numerous
then the process of dimerization of two
her2 receptors next to one another
or that's called homodymerization or
heterodymerization between her2 receptor
and another epidermal growth factor
receptor
family protein whether it's her one her
four or her three
that diagnorization triggers these
pathways
uh basically activates these pathways
and
enables them to send signals
downstream that will really affect the
potential aggressiveness of the cancer
cell and the cancer itself
okay so
let's jump straight into some
misconceptions
and that's really uh basically a summary
of the phone calls i get from my
colleagues who are either oncologists or
pathologists
asking me hey you probably messed up my
the results of my patients
didn't you pay attention to the tumor
grade and whatnot
so we'll go over these um one by one
so the um first of all
uh one of these misconceptions is
low-grade tumors are always
her2-negative
that's actually right and not
right you know so that is correct uh in
the majority of the cases but not
always correct and then the special type
tumors like globular mucinous and
tubular tumors
are always too negative again that is
largely correct
but uh has some exceptions which
we will go over and tumor with
incomplete membranous signal
are her2 negative that is
not necessarily true and then the last
one is
most her2 positive tumors are high grade
that also is not necessarily true
we will go over some examples to
illustrate the point of each one of
these items
so this is a a tumor on low
magnification it looks like well that's
a nottingham grade one
tumor which is true that is a grade one
tumor
and it should not be her2 positive as a
result of that well
lo and behold this is the her2 status of
this tumor
by ifc and by fish and her2
is definitively unequivocally positive
on this tumor that has a nottingham
grade 1
or 5 phenotype but if we look at the
tumor nuclei up close we we notice that
actually they're not necessarily
they don't have a nuclear score of one
they have a nuclear score of two and
focally three even so
that is the point i want to illustrate
tumors with a nuclear score of higher
than one
all bets are off so you can actually
have a nottingham grade 1 tumor
that is her2 positive and i just showed
you one example of that
now that is admittedly that is not
common but it happens and we should be
aware of that phenomenon that
basically what i tell pathologists is
all of you are molecular pathologists
whether you like it or not because you
look at the h
e and when you look at the h and e slide
you're looking at the nuclei
and the nuclei i have the blueprint of
the cell
and the blueprint includes the dna and
the the dna
is really important so in my opinion the
nottingham
score uh should incorporate the
if you look at the nuclear score the
nottingham grade has the nuclear tubular
amplimorphism
i'm sorry nuclear polymorphism tubular
score and mitotic index
if you take the nuclear score in
isolation
any tumor that has a nuclear score of
one which is
extremely low grade almost like benign
these tumors are never
ever or two positive and i use the word
never actually i've never seen one
that's her2 positive with a nuclear
score of one
but once the nuclear score is two and
higher actually you can have
potentially you can have uh her2
protein expression as a result of gene
amplification
those tumors with protein expression
secondary to gene amplification
if you look at the copy number of the
genes it actually is low
but it's positive when it is positive
so this is an example of one of these
scenarios where a grade one tumor is
actually her2 positive and that's
one of the most common phone calls i get
like oh you messed up the score of my
tumor no i didn't
it just happened that the nuclear score
is more than one
and and if we have that
it's okay for any breast cancer to be
her2 positive
majority of them are not but there are
exceptions i showed you one of them now
this tumor is you know any pathologist
would look at this would say okay this
looks like a lobular tumor which is
correct that's an invasive lobular
carcinoma
and guess what it is positive for her to
protein expression that's a three plus
signal that i don't think anybody would
argue against
and but we look at the tumor cells
up close again these tumor cells are
higher score they have a higher nuclear
score than
than your classical lobular cancers
and they have a higher nuclear score
therefore they
can be positive majority of lobular
cancers are not
positive but the tumors with a higher
nuclear score
especially the pleomorphic lobulars can
be
can be occasionally positive over two
standard and this is the
fish result again on this tumor we do
see definitive amplification but the
number of gene copies is not
exceedingly high it's still in the
single digits like 7 to 9 but it's not
higher than 10 and that's typical of
these tumors when they are positive
in my experience this is an example of a
tumor that
anybody would call mucinous carcinoma
and that's fine
uh but this tumor is also positive
you know for her2-protein expression uh
again we look at the nuclei up close the
nuclear score the nuclear score
is not necessarily one it's actually two
so any of these and fish is positive in
this again
it's generally largely a single digit
copy number but it looks like actually
double digit but in the lower double
digit
in this case like maybe 12 copies on
average
so these tumors can be
positive generally speaking they're
negative but i would like to
alert the pathologists in the audience
uh that
when you have a museum's tumor with the
nuclear
score of higher than one i actually
personally do not call it business
i would say invasive doctor carcinoma
maybe you can say amusement features
you know but i will alert the oncologist
that the nuclear score is higher than
one and should not be called mucinous
because biologically
it's not going to be to behave like your
typical
mucinous store so
let's now spend a few minutes on the
focus
2018 update which i actually
participated in
and was a lively discussion with a
number of very experienced colleagues
so we have
a scenario here where the ratio is over
two
[Music]
but the average her2 copy number is less
than four and i have a cartoon
of a tumor cell with three copies three
or two copies but one chromosome 17 copy
so if you divide three over one you get
a ratio of three that's higher than two
but the average or two copy number is
less than four
now if you recall according to the 2013
guidelines
this tumor with this kind of a ratio
score
would be actually called positive and
that was one of the most contentious
topics
uh discussed in the during the 2013
guideline deliberation
because the pathologists in the room
really didn't want to call these tumors
positive but the oncologist wanted to
give the patient the benefit of the
child and see
if we treat these patients what the
outcome would be
um after data would accumulate
which is fine with me
so the 2018 guidelines actually reverse
these tumors
and would default to the her2 protein
status in these tumors to determine
fish status this is the other category
where the ratio score is less than two
but the her2 copy number is more than
six so that is
group three the previous one
this one is group two this is group
three
okay these used to be called positive
flat out but
now we have to defer to uh her2 protein
status
and then the largest category uh among
these
is basically group four tumors
uh which has a ratio of uh
still less than two but an average or
two company number between four
instances
okay so we'll go over these one by one
obviously immunist chemistry there was
no change
to no significant change to the
designation of her to
protein expression and then
just a very quick word about fish single
probe my understanding
is vast majority of laboratories when i
get the
cap survey i look at the numbers of labs
that do
her two single probe tests and
these labs are rare actually that do a
single protest
uh so this is a diagram for these single
protests
it's actually more simple because you
don't have a ratio score
um but the more complicated ones
are the tumors with
you know when you do the testing with a
dual probe because you have to do a
ratio score but you still have to pay
attention to the
single or two average copy number
so these tumors are grouped in uh five
different groups as a result we talked
about group two
three and four in the middle uh group
one is your straightforward group
uh with uh positive results which is
basically fifteen to twenty four
20 percent of breast cancers and that is
the
group of tumors with a ratio more than
two and an average copy number of more
than four
or equal to equal to or greater than
four
and then on the far right side of the
slide we have group five
with a basically straightforward
negative result
with an average copy number of less than
four
and a ratio score of less than two that
is the
most common setting and in between we
have group 2 3 and 4 and we're going to
spend more time on these
with the dual color i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on this diagram
which you have in your handout but
basically group two is we talked about a
ratio of uh higher than two but an
average copy number of less than
four and these tumors
when we do ihc so ihc immunostatic
chemistry is the adjudicator
of her2fish status and that's a new
thing that was
implemented and introduced as a result
of the 2018 focused update
which basically says if you have a tumor
that is a group two
okay you're gonna actually do immunistic
chemistry regardless if you did it
before you did fish or you
or you're going to do it after you do
first now my
my suggestion to you is to always do
imminent chemistry because you may end
up with some
even though you do fish on everything
but always do ministry chemistry
because you may end up with a scenario
where the
gene status is negative but the protein
status is positive
so this is one of those scenarios where
the protein status will determine the
gene status so
basically to simplify things
you don't have to look at the diagram
just you can listen to me
if the protein status is shows a one
plus or two plus signal
then we would call the fish study
negative
if the protein status is replaced then
we would call the fish study positive
which is i think is a good approach and
i would agree with
now group three tumors uh is the one
that has
a higher copy number equal to
or greater than six and uh these tumors
but the ratio is
less than two and these tumors have that
because of an increased
copy number of the control probe which
is chromosome 17 centromere probe
now these used to be called positive
straight out
but now we subject them to the exact
same algorithm we subject group
2 so if her2ihc status
is the oneplus or zero negative
we call these tumors negative if it's
three plus positive we call them
positive
the only difference between this and
group two and subsequent group four
which we will see in a minute
is when ihc shows an equivocal signal
actually we do call this tumor
positive now in my personal experience
when i get a tumor like this with a copy
number of six and higher
and a ratio of less than two um
generally speaking ihc status is
actually positive
so i don't have to worry about ic being
negative
[Music]
but if ihc shows an equivocal two plus
signal we would call these tumors
actually possible now the next tumor
which is the
group four which is really the most
common scenario
in these gray zone tumors group two
three and four
with group four it is exactly the same
algorithm of group two so if you have
an ihc signal intensity
of either zero one or two plus
we would call the tumor negative
by fish if ihc status is three plus
positive
we call the tumor positive by which so
that's identical
to group two but group three is
different
now if we put all these together in a
single slide
basically on the left you have ihc
scores
and on the right you have fish scores
and the combination of
these two would dictate her two fish
status
so again to recap tumors with the zero
or one plus signal
by ihc would be called negative across
the board by fisch
regardless of the group designation
uh tumors that are i that show ih3 plus
by
uh signal which is positive
they would be called positive by fish
regardless of the group designation
the only difference where fish
group designation makes a difference is
when we have an equivocal
ihc2 plus score but the
tumor shows group 3 status by fish
which is basically an average of six and
higher or two copy numbers but
but the ratio score of less than two
these tumors if ihc shows two plus they
would actually be
called uh positive okay so
uh that is the only difference so that's
a nice slide that i put together
to illustrate to summarize the entire uh
situation with these grease on grayson
turmeric now my prediction which
actually
is correct i i made this slide uh
um right at the beginning in in
june of uh 2019
uh to sh to predict that actually we
would we will end up
as a result of the focused update we
will end up with a
higher number of
her2 negative tumors as a result which
is true
and that percentage is is at least
higher by five percent
now to recap the guidelines
um there was actually heavy reliance
on the if you look at bullet number four
uh
there was heavy reliance on the nsabp
uh b47 trial um
which i have a little bit of a problem
with because they lumped
patients with one plus and two plus
scores together and they were not really
stratified
and the patients with one plus and two
plus scores they were excluded from the
treatment trial
from the treatment group they don't
qualify so
in my opinion actually generally
speaking the focused update did a very
good job
looking at these grazon tumors in a more
granular way
and incorporated the protein status to
stratify these tumors as to which ones
should be called negative and which ones
should be called positive
so i'm fairly satisfied with the uh
guidelines
now just a quick word about griezon
tumors grayson tumors
the way i define them don't are not
exclusive
to groups two three and four in my
opinion you can actually have a positive
tumor that we call positive no problem
uh but that's also a grazon tumor for
example if you have a tumor with four
or two copies on average and two
chromosome copies we would call that
straightforward positive
it's basically group one but to me
that tumor is no different than groups
two three and four
because the copy number is low so the
point i'm trying to make
is when you have a tumor with a copy
number near
the cutoff you really want to
slow down and look at those tumors
more carefully to sort them out
you know because to me they're just like
group two three and four but they're
classified as either either group one or
group five depending on
the count
and these tumors seem to have a biology
that is a little bit more aggressive by
the way
this is an example of a tumor that shows
um a let's say
six over four copies um
and it's inside a vessel and i and i put
a dashed line
to highlight the endothelial lining of
the capillary where these tumor cells
are inside
so that's a vascular invasion vascular
invasion is a sign of aggression he's an
aggressive tumor obviously
it's a core prognostic sign so that's a
patient that's a tumor with a poor
prognostic sign with a gray zone
score so the gray zone scores are not
limited to
low grade tumors actually that you see
high grade tumors with more gray zone
results you know so we have to be
careful with those numbers
another one look at the nuclear grade
it's actually high
this is roughly speaking three over two
this is four over three again roughly
speaking
um that's again is the high grade tumor
i mean you look at these nuclei they're
cleomorphic they're
large they're they have an irregular
contour
all of the cytologic features that we
recognize as as high grade
so what do i do
you know to manage these grazon tumors
obviously i follow the guidelines i
still follow the guidelines
but i pay more attention to the hormone
receptors
obviously her2 ihc status and also
other things like t67 e67 is very
important to look at
to stratify these tumors if it's high
and happens to be er falsitive it would
be
luminal b tumor basically um
i look at pr pr if it's negative or low
that actually is a poor prognostic
marker
when you have pr being negative or low
regardless of er status
especially when it's accompanied by a
relatively higher p67
p67 doesn't have to be as high as 20
it could be between 10 and 20 with a
with a low
pr status then that tumor would actually
qualify as a luminal b
and biologically and clinically probably
would would behave as aluminum be
tower and then there is space for the
risk assessment
assays which is the favorite thing for
medical oncologists to order
to sort out these patients and they get
virtual status
indirectly now just a word of caution
these risk assessment
risk assessment assays that incorporate
her to testing
results in them they're really not
approved by the fda
for determination of her two status so
it's just an informative essay but it's
not a
approved to determine her two status
with again eligibility of treatment
so that's a word of caution um so
this is another way just by text to
illustrate what i just
said in the previous slide
and the practical approach you know
which i hope
would be incorporated in the next
guidelines which
i would like to call these tumors grow
too low the grazing tumors call them
her2
low instead of either positive or
negative so there would be three
categories first two positive
that is kind of straightforward her two
negative that's straightforward and then
in between
we call it we're too low and that
encompasses group
three two three and four you know so her
too
low obviously we don't know how they
behave probably
biologically and clinically they behave
more like a negative tumor
but we don't know yet all right so
um let's spend a few minutes on the
special scenarios i think we're
not behind the time it's been 20 minutes
since
i started so we'll talk about
heterogeneity we'll talk about we'll
talk about
polysomy versus co-amplification and
then we'll show a few examples of
uncommon hybridization patterns so this
is a tumor which
clearly shows the heterogeneity you have
tumor cells with basically
no amplification and other next to them
adjacent tumor cells with
actually a very high number of gene
copies
significant amplification so that's
heterogeneity it does happen
but it's not common to be honest with
you i don't see it
commonly and that's heterogeneity by
immunistic chemistry that parallels the
heterogeneity with fish
and that's another example of
heterogeneity where you have occasional
just only occasional positive cells but
the majority of the tumor is either too
plus or negative
and now this is an important uh slide
because it shows
uh the tumor actually is barely two plus
and it's actually negative by krish
but the there is an associated in situ
component and then cytocomponent is
positive so these tumors
you know because um if if those
if if this kind of a tumor is sent to
uh for oncotype dx risk assessment
sometimes you may get actually a
positive or two result and in your
laboratory as a pathologist you reported
her to result as
negative or equivocal by ihc and maybe
negative bypass
then you get the result from uh of
oncotype dx as
positive her2 status being positive
what would have happened in a case like
this is because the microdissection
doesn't really
factor in the dcis it's not you know
like scientific micro dissection where
you
only dissect the invasive tumor her2
status is really a reflection of
the dcis in this case and that's
important you know and and the company
that does
uh archetype dx pays attention to this
and they actually send the slides to us
uh to adjudicate her to status when
there's a discrepancy between the
original apology
her2 result and the oncotype dx what we
do is we dissect
we map these tumors with immunochemistry
amphis and we show them her2 status by
on the incitor component and invasive
components so what they do is they take
the slide
we digitally scan it for them and they
actually only dissect the invasive
component
and repeat the whole asset repeat the
whole risk assessment assay to
completely exclude the incitor component
which actually is an accurate reflection
of the risk associated only with the
invasive disease you know
which is actually important
all right so let's talk about some
uncommon hybridization patterns
uh this is a tumor with an amplification
of chromosome 17 centromere uh
this does happen it's extremely rare it
was described
for the first time actually in 2006 by
my colleague and friend dr megan troxl
when she was at ohsu as she described it
for the first time
um this is an example of monosomy now
this is more common
this is more common where you see a
single copy of chromosome 17
and regardless of her2 protein
gene status you see a single single copy
so that
is probably a reflection of a deletion
of the other allele we don't know unless
we do
a ray cgh on these tumors but this is
more common i
i actually do see this about
1 out of 50 tumors so it's two percent
two percent of the tumors have this kind
of uh genotype
and this is exceedingly rare or we
actually have a her2 deletion there's a
deletion of her two
gene either a single probe deletion or
even double probe division but in this
case it's a single probe deletion
that happens but again it's exceedingly
rare but i have seen it this one is the
other way where you have a combination
of her2 gene amplification associated
with monotony
and then with immunochemistry uh what i
refer to these
to this phenotype is the equivalent of
the quote-unquote bile canalicular
phenotype which is similar to the
biochemical
pattern of polyclonal cea or cd10 or
villain that we see
in hepatocellular carcinomas we
occasionally
see this pattern with her with breast
cancers
with regard to her2 protein biominister
chemistry
and that should not actually be called
negative it should be called as
equivocal or you can call it
indeterminate if you're not
comfortable calling it equivocal you can
call it indeterminate
and these tumors
a small fraction of them by the way are
is
positive for her to gene amplification
so my
recommendation is each time you see this
kind of what i refer to as the
biochemical pattern
you have to i don't think you have a
choice you have to
perform a two fish tests to sort these
out
majority of them are actually negative
admittedly
but a minority of them is positive and
the minority that is positive
shows a stronger signal
of the per2 membranous signal
so the point i'm trying to drive home
here
is you do not have to have a continuous
circumferential signal around the
cell if you have a
discontinuous signal like this one which
looks almost like a biconnector pattern
pay attention to it
don't call it negative call it either
two plus or indeterminate
which will trigger a fish test and then
the fish
assay will really determine her2 status
it could be positive could be negative
majority are negative but some are
positive
and again this tumor actually this very
tumor you just looked at
has a positive uh signal count with her2
her2 is positive in this case by gene uh
status
just very quick word about polysomy
versus complication this is the exact
same tumor
with two different filters used to take
the picture on the left you have
her2 gene which shows an average of i
would say six to seven
copies and on the right you have
chromosome 17 only
which shows an identical number of
chromosomes centromere copies so what
happened here is it polysomine
we used to think it's polystomy
um which illustrated by
the fact that there are just an
increased number of copies of chromosome
17
allele we actually were wrong
all along which we were proven wrong
by my very good friend dr
shelly gunn and her colleagues and also
by
a group from italy the same year
in 2009 the two investigative groups
published papers showing
basically uh if you do cgh testing
um polysomnia of chromosome chromosome
17 and breast cancer at least
is basically non-existent um
and that was the you know and you see
the red
circle surrounding the chromosome 17 it
says
zero so out of the hundred tumors that
they run cgh
on to validate the assay for breast
cancer
none of them showed polystomine
what we used to refer to as polychromy
is actually not polythermi
which probably
would be a result of potential
co-amplification of the centromere along
with the gene
kind of a level amplification i don't
really have the answer but
but it should not be referred to as
polysome anymore
now in the next few minutes we're going
to talk about
how to improve the accuracy of virtual
testing
using tools that we already have we
don't have to use
some fancy other tests like quantitative
pcr which is a very good test
or cgh which is a very good test but in
my opinion we don't have to use those
tests in the majority of
of cases so
what do we do okay
the small tumor category we'll go over
that
in the next slide a tumor with a nuclear
score of one
these are invariably negative so looking
at the morphology looking at the nuclear
score
if you feel as a pathologist then the
nuclear score is one
these tumors should not be positive and
in my opinion
a nuclear score of one is the strongest
predictor of a negative or two protein
and gene status actually
now two more with t67 so i really like
to look at p67 if you have less than
five percent
these tumors uh are not really supposed
to be positive for her2
but i cannot say they're never positive
but they're not supposed to be positive
so p67 is a good
really adjunct to help you determine
her2 status indirectly
and then you have the specific
histologic features
for example the metaplastic carcinomas
uh including spindle cell carcinoma
which is known also as a
fibromatosis-like tumor we published a
study
uh as i was finishing my fellowship at
md anderson with dr snage showing that
none of these tumors are actually
positive so spinoza carcinomas when you
have a metaplastic carcinoma whether
it's spindle cell or maybe squamous
these tumors are we can say
with some confidence that they are
invariably
for her2 protein expression and
de-amplification
and then you have these non-mammary
tumors for example the salivary gland
type tumors like the adenoid cystic
carcinomas it's not really
even though it's triple negative but
it's not your classical
triple negative that looks basal-like
these tumors are triple negative
we say triple negative meaning negative
over two
almost always negative for her2 protein
expression and
gene amplification with rare exceptions
i used to say invariably negative
until i learned my lesson one time i had
an adenoids carcinoma that shows a low
level
protein expression and gene
amplification so i stopped saying they
were unvariably negative
almost invariably negative another
special type is the micro papillary
invasive micro papillary carcinoma these
tumors it's like
exactly flipping a coin 50
of them show positivity so they have a
higher percentage
of them of that group being positive
compared to general breast invasive
breast cancer which is 15 to 20
when it comes to invasive micropapillary
carcinomas
these tumors actually uh
50 of them are positive with a caveat
the ones that are positive
they do not show a higher
a very high her2 gene copy number so
they show
something in the single digits usually
seven eight nine
maybe ten maybe eleven maybe twelve but
not in the higher
double digit and then the
actual tumors that are positive what is
the phenotype of these tumors we're
going to go over
that in the next slide but let's first
talk about the size of the tumor
and how it impacts virtue status how it
impacts the accuracy
of virtual status obviously the size
doesn't change the status
but a tumor with a smaller size
has a more likely tendency to
have an accurate test result and why is
that
so i i created the slides to illustrate
my point so if you have a larger tumor
generally speaking we don't sample the
entire tumor
so there's some of it left in the
container
and when we sample it let's say we take
four slides
five i'm sorry four blocks or five
blocks six blocks okay
out of these six blocks we only test one
so if there is heterogeneity we really
don't know about
the rest of the blocks the routine
practice and i'm not advocating for
testing all of the blocks no
one block is enough but the denominator
because when we say
10 percent is the cutoff between
positive and negative
right when you have a small tumor
the entire tumor more often than not is
sampled in a single block
and is represented on a single slide
the entire tumor so when we say okay we
do have some heterogeneity with maybe
two percent positive cell so we're going
to call it negative
the denominator in this case is actually
accurate because we have a full
representation of the entire tumor
when it's a small tumor but when it's a
large tumor and we have heterogeneity
and we say and the and we have some
positivity but it is less than five
percent or ten percent
we really don't have a clue about the
denominator
10 percent of what 10 percent of tumor
cells in a single block
but we don't have the rest of the blocks
and
we haven't sampled the entire tumor so
the accuracy of her2 result
is maximized when you have a small tumor
it's inversely related
when you have a large tumor you may have
to test additional blocks or maybe all
the blocks
when you have heterogeneity so that's
the point to take home
is accuracy of her2 status is in first
inversely related in my opinion
to the tumor size smaller tumors are
represented on a single cassette
usually larger tumors are not
now what do her two positive tumors look
like we all have seen them
but i would like to describe them you
see
the cytoplasm here on the low
magnification it looks a little bit
[Music]
kind of pinkish i think almost like
apocrine but not exactly like apocrine
i like to call it it's like a almost
like a hybrid between apocrine and
squamous so i like to call it
hybrid it's quaker i like to use that
term
and this tumor is clearly positive
and up close obviously the
nuclear grade is nuclear score it's two
to three so it's a pleomorphic
but you look at the cytoplasm there are
two things about the cytoplasm not that
it's only
pink but also if you look at the nc
ratio the nuclear to cytoplasmic ratio
the ratio is not high it actually is
low because there's a ton of cytoplasm i
don't know what it is
that enable these virtual positive
tumors to
to make a lot of cytoplasm so as a
result
the nucleus still looks ugly but the nc
ratio is actually generally speaking
it's low
not always but generally speaking it is
low that's another tumor that looks more
like a almost like a
sugar tumor you know you have a more
clear cell cytoplasm
and the with a low nc ratio look at the
nc ratio is not necessarily high it's
actually low
but you look at the nuclei they are ugly
they are
they have a score of two or even three
in some cases
that's clearly a positive tumor and then
you have the microcapillary obviously
when you have a microcapillary invasive
microcapillary caustic normal
when sorry about that when you have an
invasive microcapillary carcinoma
the 50 of these tumors are positive
okay and the signal is not continuous
that's another thing to pay attention to
you're not going to get a
circumferential signal
in these tumors and that's as good as it
gets if you want to call this two plus
i'm fine with that but when you do fish
on it
actually there is a positive signal
and notice the copy number is not
necessarily how it's in the single
digits and that's my experience with
these numbers
so to put it all together
how do we perform the qa program at our
institution
the invasive tumor is verified on the h
e slide obviously and our lab is a
hybrid lab we do get cases from the
local community where we diagnose
the invasive cancer on core biopsies
usually
from imaging centers but the majority of
our her2 testing is actually referred to
us by other pathology
labs so we make an h e
we look at it obviously we make sure
there is an invasive tumor on the h e
and we always invariably even when the
client asks us to do fish
only we invariably perform ihc and i
refer to it
for tumor mapping we map the tumor make
sure if there is heterogeneity if there
are hot spots
we we focus on those hot spots when we
interpret the fish result okay
so that's a tumor mapping okay and then
when i'm looking at the fish slide i
always look at the h and e and ifc
at the same time i'm looking at the fish
slide
okay so we have a qa program looking at
the tumor
nuclear score tumor histologic grade
ihc score and fish score one by one side
by side
and in that specific sequence the
reading is performed by a pathologist
myself or someone else
and i am purposely blinded
to the previous results i don't want to
bias myself
if the if we have a previous sample on
the
same patient i would i don't want to
bias myself when i'm interpreting the
new sample
but what i do is when i get to verify
the case in the final report
i look at the previous studies and i do
compare obviously and if there is
discrepancy i go back to the slides and
i dig a little bit deeper uh
of the new slides and the old slides to
see why there is discrepancy
and of course the metrics are mandated
by the
clia and the college of american plazas
or other regulatory agencies
so we perform the metrics i prefer
monthly metrics over quarterly metrics
in case you have a little bit of a drift
in your essay
you can catch it sooner but the good
news about this program
is really what i like to refer to as
real time
real time quality control
where you're looking at the slides side
by side for
every tumor in real time before you
report the status
and that's it that's if you look at i
actually took a picture of a
folder with a few breast cancers
showing h e ihd and fish
h e ihc and fish that is our quality
insurance program
um and again we talked about how we can
predict
her2 status by looking at the h e or
even looking at the ihc obviously
and finally um
i have put together a slide
uh that explains my approach to her two
status
and so obviously on the let's focus
first on the right side
of the slide where you have her two
negative tumors that's group
five and the her2 low tumors which i
talked about which is the gray zone
which encompasses group two
three and four and then uh
the her2 positive tumors now there are
two positive tumors are not
homogeneous they are heterogeneous
how do i split them i look at
first of all i look at her erpr status
i look at the nuclear score i look at
the morphology
and i look at or two i'm sorry t67
status and it should make sense
to separate these two pockets so the uh
what i like to refer to as the luminal
vert2 which is
basically er positive pr positive these
tumors have a nuclear score of usually
two
even one or two is positive and the copy
number is generally low in the single
visit
or low double digit and then you look at
e67
the percentage of positive cells is
between 10 and 20.
now the tumors that are her2 positive
but er negative
um these tumors have the typical
what i like to refer to as
schweppercrine morphology
the nuclear score is higher usually
three
and then you look at the her2 fish copy
number is actually
higher it is it is not usually single
digit it's double digit and usually it's
high double digit
and then you look at t67 status it's
actually also high between 20 and 30
and sometimes higher than 30 percent
that
group of tumor i like to refer to it as
her2 driven so her2 actually drives the
biology and clinical behavior of those
tumors
as opposed to the other group of tumors
that happens to be her2 positive but
her2 is really not the driver
it's not the driver it just happens to
be positive these tumors
in my opinion biologically and
clinically would behave as
almost close to her two negative
obviously we still have to treat them as
virtue positive
but keep in the back of our mind that
these probably the treatment
treatment her to anti her2 treatment in
these patients is not as effective and
and this is actually also confirmed by
the literature
by some of the published literature and
so the uh this is it i am
at the end now and i think we did a good
job we got uh
50 minutes or less and so the
focused updates the 2018 focused up they
really moved closer to
incorporating the protein status with
the gene status
almost on all tumors the guidelines
obviously
they already swung the pendulum in the
negative result direction
which i actually welcome to some extent
and then it did not really solve the
dilemma the grazon tumor even though
the oncologists are jubilant about the
disappearance of the equivocal her2
category but that disappearance is
actually artificial so we really
dichotomized
artificially dichotomized a continuous
variable in my opinion
and did not eliminate the problem of
grazon tumor we still have to address
that so therefore i personally propose
that three-tier scoring uh
her too positive or too negative or too
low
and i think dr shelly gunn my colleague
who does a lot of uh
cgas comparative genomic hybridization
testing sheets all agree with that
conclusion
and of course correlation with
immunistic chemistry and tumor
histopathology
and performing the metrics is really in
my opinion mandatory in order to improve
or to testing accuracy
this is really the most important
statement and this is the message i
would like for everybody
to take home and with that i really
appreciate your attention and i welcome
your questions at
this point at this point thank you
thank you dr yaziji for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the q the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q
a box our first question is
what do you do with low-grade tumors
that have a her2-positive status by
either immunohistochemistry
or fish sure
thank you jennifer um basically
i apply the same tools that i get in the
toolbox
basically i always use the same tools i
have in the toolbox i pull them out
low brake tumors generally speaking are
not supposed to be
or too positive but like i said earlier
there are exceptions and the exceptions
follow a specific rule that rule
says at least the rule that i
observed over more than looking at more
than
23 000 tumors is
basically the nuclear score
if the nuclear score is one
then the tumor should really be negative
should not be positive i have not seen a
tumor that is positive
for her2 with a nuclear score of one out
of three
but when the nuclear score becomes
higher than one
either two or three out of three then
all bets are off
and the tumor actually is allowed for
the lack of a better word
is allowed to be or too positive
so it is perfectly fine
for breast cancers to be positive when
they are low grade
with a with the condition that the
nuclear score is higher than one now if
you have a nuclear score of
one and a positive status you really
should not have that combination so you
should
if you only have a munister chemistry
you should do fish maybe there's
something wrong with the assay with the
ihc assay
you should do fish and fish would be
negative and maybe the ihc assay
shows some high sensitivity issues
sometimes the fixation of the tumor
plays a role in bumping the
her2 status i have never seen a a three
plus positive tumor
that is with a artificially three plus
signal by ihc
but i have seen tumors with like what
looks like convincingly two plus signal
um and which is really not
representative of two plus but it's more
like should be one plus
and the increase in the intensity is due
to
shorter fixation of the tumor and
formaldehyde so what happens is when
they
get to the tissue processor the next
solution that they are hit
with the tumor is hit with is actually
alcohol
and alcohol brings up the signal her two
signal you know
so her two likes alcohol and and so you
get artificially
a more intense her2 protein copy by hc
but you do fish
and and you get negative results so
that's what i do with these tumors
okay and
our next question is can you please
elaborate more
on the her2 driven tumors sure
so that is one of my favorite areas
because
that's where we need to get a little bit
more granular
and go beyond the dichotomy of positive
versus negative
okay so having a her2 positive status
is not the end of the story and that
really shows
where the medical oncologist a very
astute
medical oncologist would really look
beyond the positive result
so they put it all together so if the
tumor is
positive for her to protein expression
and or gene amplification
and negative for more hormone receptors
with a
really higher nuclear grade but also
a high t67 for people who do perform
e67 assay
if you put it all together a
tumor that is negative for hormone
receptor expression but positive for her
too
these are the tumors this is the group
of tumors where i personally feel that
the patient gets the most
benefit of anti-heritage therapy and
that therapy
is unopposed by the hormone receptor
status on the tumor
because there is good literature a
couple of studies that show that
patients who have
positive hormone receptor status for
some reason the positive status
tends to block the beneficial effects of
anti-her2 therapy
as opposed to patients with a her2
driven tumor where the protein the
hormone receptor is actually completely
negative
so that's why i like to call these
tumors driven by her2 because r2 seems
to really drive the biology and the
clinical course
in these patients
okay great well those are all the
questions we have
thank you again dr hattie yazoji and
thank you again to the audience
for those outstanding questions we hope
you found today's presentation to be
informative and insightful
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time
goodbye